[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand nous sommes là ça nous rappelle
les là où on vient ça nous rappelle
combien de fois la langue qu'on parle
très important
avec l'ambassade de France qui dit que
là le traitement la région de la graisse
certainement les touristes ne sont pas
confiants ils sont pas confiants c'est
pourquoi nous avons mis tous ces
dispositifs là pour les rassurer
et à cette époque le tourisme sont
libres maintenant avec l'insécurité même
nous qui habitent dans les régions
on n'a pas
de grandes volontiers d'aller quelque
part plus forte raison et quelqu'un qui
vient d'ailleurs donc c'est ça qui fait
que je pense pas qu'il y aura de
tourisme qu'on connaît d'avant